greetings my friends and welcome to a
funny Christmas review let us venture
into our very last Christmas film that
we're reviewing is Alf really this is
the last one we're going out on elf
people either seem to love or hate Will
Ferrell and you sure we want to go out
on this one I mean okay let's talk about
elf this world fair oh he's an elf
high jinks there's some other characters
in the movie they're boring high jinks
I'm sorry but what do you say about this
movie I mean it's it's not good it's not
bad it's just Alf
now if Alf was an elf that would be
awesome in fact maybe he is maybe he was
like an elf back on his original planet
where all their noses are ripped for her
pleasure
I think they should remake elf and make
it without in fact elf and elf can have
a giant battle together al can use all
these alien ships of weaponry and elf
can use all the satanic powers of Santa
and L can be like that you see that a
throne of lies and L can be like I kill
me Christmas and then just well looks
like all hope is lost and the whole
world is gonna be destroyed by these two
abominations of God Bruce Willis comes
in using a dick down version of
Ralphie's BB gun yet because a
and then Jack Skellington comes in
bringing all his Halloween buddies
thinking an epic battle with the
rankin/bass stop-motion characters The
Grinch comes in and sets them all on
fire cuz you know they're puppets
Chevy Chase makes an awkward
conversation with some attractive lady
he's terrible and Charlie Brown wonders
what does it all mean oh my god I wrote
the greatest Christmas story of all time
oh wait the only thing missing is Jesus
Jesus is the referee yeah thou shalt not
be granted two points oh my god we
totally gotta make this movie
it'll cost a bajillion dollars but we'll
get everybody together and
we'll call it Christmas yeah
spread elf was the best movie to go out
on oh my god and we're gonna make the
best Christmas story of all time the
best Christmas movie the best prism sped
to the midnight you know I got cold
somebody I know jazz the person for the
job
hello I have an excellent idea for a
Christmas movie really tell me more
Merry Christmas